i want to congratulate you on cobra kai
uh
i have watched i think almost all of
them
i am loving the show uh i'm really
enjoying it
it seems like the perfect show right now
because um it's this nice dose of
nostalgia
it's really fun and the show has a great
sense of humor it's
so i'm enjoying it it's it's a great
quarantine show
what's the response you're hearing from
people well we'll take we'll take the
great quarantine i'll take the great
show no matter what but the uh it is the
i call it the comfort food you know it's
it's that big fat nostalgic embrace
and yet it's telling uh relevant stories
for today and a great young cast
and uh it's just hitting on all
cylinders and um
that's this sort of blessing i mean this
has been i call it the second
rebirth of the rebirth of the original
movie you know we came out a few years
ago on youtube premium and
now netflix it's just blown out of the
water all over the world and it's yeah
it's it's a great time for the show and
it's nice to be
um an alternative to the hell that we're
we are living with every day and i'll
tell you how you're affecting my life
which is one of the ways you know right
now in addition to quarantine we've also
have
uh so much smoke in the air here in the
west
you can't go outside i have a treadmill
in the basement
it's in a tiny room and there's a small
tv there and i will binge watch cobra
kai
and i'm on the treadmill and what
happens is when it builds up to a fight
scene
i crank the treadmill so i'm running at
like 60 miles an hour
bare chested it's not a pretty it's not
a pretty sight
i'll get a picture because you clearly
want one but i'm running full out
as the kid is beating up the bullies in
the cafeteria and i'm like
my family comes running downstairs
because they think i've had
a major heart attack right back right
yeah
and it's in the show is uh laced with
this great
80s homage music yes
that time the training montages and all
that stuff it is
it is uh kick ass in that way and that's
that's awesome well i'm
i'm glad to help out in your cardio and
everything else
yes it's you know you mentioned 80s and
nostalgia i've got some pictures here
i'm sure your life has been being
confronted by these pictures
yes yeah exactly uh
first of all let's sue the guy who
convinced you to do that pose i know i
know
there's so many there's many others that
that is not the one i'm actually glad
that was the one you well let's see
what's next no no no no i've got this
one
too oh well that's from a movie that's
from a movie that's your
movie with nick nolte i know i know i
know but
uh any kid who's wearing that hat to
school needs to know karate
[Laughter]
you uh you know it's funny because all
these pictures
i i you and i think are just about the
same age
and there are the saving grace for me is
there are no photographs of me until i'm
about
30. i was unphotographed i'm like
someone that was born in the 1850s
there's no photograph of me and then
they start around the time i'm 29 or 30.
what's it like for your kids when
they're on the internet and this pops up
and they say
dad what the thinking
and it gives them leverage great amounts
of leverage yeah
um it's uh you know i mean what are you
what are you gonna do it's kind of fun
because when my kids were
my daughter was like four when she first
saw the karate kid maybe five
and um and so it was one of those things
we were we were tour i was doing a a
broadway musical around the country uh
called how to succeed and i was playing
the lead in the show
and every city we would go to these
planet hollywoods which were big deals
back in the early 90s
and we grabbed lunch there with the with
uh
my kids and my daughter would see this
memorabilia up and ask these questions
like
why are people standing on one leg and
holding their arms up in the air when
they see daddy and
what is that headband why are they
wearing it
and then finally it was like well you
know it's time to sit you down honey
daddy's not like all the other daddies
um and then we i showed her the film at
four years old literally karate kid at
four yeah five
five years old like it was five because
we got back when she was five and i
showed her that and and thinking that it
would i
would make her proud and and not not
thinking that i get my ass kicked in
every other scene
and she's watching her dad be beaten
to out of the room so that was uh
an epic parent fail by by me yeah you
scarred your child for life
yeah um although i have to say my
children at any point in their lives
would love nothing more than to see
footage of being beaten
it might have changed to that when she
got through middle school but at five
she really you know i was a hero for a
moment yeah
and my son my son on the flip side found
all those teen magazine kind of pictures
when he was about
the same age and ran into
the family room to my daughter and said
look dad was huge and we missed it
so so fortunately for me right now with
cobra's ice show
uh that may not be that huge but they're
not missing it
well uh what you guys have been like the
number one show on yeah we are huge
let's say
huge i mean let's just say that this is
uh
and and you know another thing i want to
say about the show that i i really love
is there's a sense there's a real funny
sense of humor and self-awareness about
the show
so i love there are these scenes where
johnny lawrence you know uh the bully in
the original karate kid
he's struggling and he doesn't
understand that the 80s are over
and he's touching scenes where he's like
trying to hock his
he's trying to sell his atari console
right we don't give a [ __ ] about this
anymore
um he's very good at at tapping into
it's almost in a comical way he doesn't
understand
that it hasn't been the 80s for a long
time he missed someone didn't
tell him that things have changed yeah
it's refreshing to have a character like
that
who is not politically correct in any
way shape or form and represent a lot of
what
a lot of many people think but can't or
won't say
so i think there's a release with that
because we're so overprotective of
everything yes
the anti-hero and you know you root for
that redemption that's the cool thing
about the show
is it really your allegiance to each
character can change episode to episode
right because it dives more into the
gray areas of who
these guys are and even the young
characters as opposed to the black and
white of what karate kid was good or
evil you know right
well what's happened interestingly
enough is that
initially karate kid and i remembered
seeing it in the theater when it came
out
uh was about you know you
are clearly the protagonist you're the
underdog
you're the hero and then it's clear who
uh the bully is johnny lawrence
what happened over time and it's kind of
a tribute to the
film is that people got into these these
discussion groups
and it sort of became part of uh almost
a cultural question of
real bully right because he has the
cruel sensei and you have the nice
sensei
you take his girlfriend you know
and and it it it became um those are the
intellectual discussions of our time
basically you've laid it out you've laid
it out beautifully
yeah it's it has become pop culture i
mean it's really become that there are
fan videos
theories the crane kick was illegal um
you know you say he took
his girlfriend well you know she was uh
i mean we could go on and on about that
i defend uh
i defend larusso but it's fun it's fun
to people
care i mean they've cared for 35 36
years
and now it's um it's lifted to another
level
um but ralph ralph be honest there are
times when you wake
up in the middle of the night covered in
sweat screaming the crane kick
was legal more more often than you know
i must confess on the conan o'brien show
do you ever do that do you ever
getting a latte and someone's just
giving you a look a little a little like
it was legal it was it was funny
i'm doing that i'm doing it i love it
well
every every day this week i'm doing that